This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars and I am standing in the Galapagos in front of a Congress of Marine iguanas. They're piled on top of each other. Occasionally if you can make it through the sound of the waves and the wind, you can hear them spitting out. So water from their nose. They just sneeze on each other and lie on each other. And they seem like they enjoy life pretty well. Last week, I was in the Galapagos Islands, which for me is the ultimate travel destination. I'm on Fernandina Islands with the marine iguanas,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯，我正站在加拉帕戈斯群岛上，面对着一群海鬣蜥。它们层层叠叠地堆在一起。偶尔，如果你能盖过海浪和风的声音，你会听到它们从鼻子里喷水的声音。它们只是互相打喷嚏，叠躺在一起。它们看起来很享受生活。上周，我在加拉帕戈斯群岛，对生态旅游而言，这是终极目的地。我在费尔南迪纳岛上，和海鬣蜥在一起。
are very plentiful. Also, the flightless comrades, who keeps his wings open, while he's just standing on a lava rock. It's really so looking. My family hiked and swam with these astounding creatures in this completely foreign landscape.
这里数量繁多。还有不会飞的鸕鹚，它站在熔岩上，翅膀张开着。这景象真的很奇特。我的家人和这些奇异的生物一起在这完全陌生的地貌中徒步和游泳。
The ground is black lava. The iguanas just match the lava. You can almost step on them. They don't move. There are no predators. They have no fear of humans at all. And you can just walk over it up to them. You don't touch them, but you just walk real close to them.
地面是黑色的熔岩。鬣蜥的颜色和熔岩完美融合。你一不小心就会踩到它们。它们一动不动。这里没有天敌。它们对人类毫无畏惧。你可以直接走到它们身边。你不能碰它们，但你可以离它们非常近。
Take a picture. And sometimes this season, you know. It was life-changing. I'll probably end up doing a story about it someday, just by myself, but fundamentally, I was there just to be there. And it was amazing. For 40 years of my life, I could barely conceive of doing this kind of trip, but I have that privilege now.
拍张照片。而且在这个季节，你知道的。这改变了我的人生。我最后可能有一天会自己写一篇关于它的报道，但从根本上说，我去那里只是为了身临其境。这太棒了。在我生命的 40 年里，我几乎不敢想象能进行这种旅行，但我现在有了这种特权。
And after leaving the islands, my first thought was, I have to do this more often. Experiencing as much of the world as possible is something that I need to place a little closer to the foundation of my hierarchy of needs. This is something the team in Atlas Obscura figured out a long time ago. Atlas Obscura is the definitive guide to the world's hidden wonders. They write books, they host experiences, they lead excursions, and they have a podcast that I really enjoy.
离开群岛后，我的第一个想法是：我必须更经常地这样。尽可能多地体验世界，是我需要放在需求层次理论更基础位置的事情。这是 Atlas Obscura 的团队很久以前就明白的道理。Atlas Obscura 是探索世界隐藏奇观的权威指南。他们写书、举办体验活动、带领远足，他们还有一个我非常喜欢的播客。
So in order for me to have enough time to take my life-changing trip, we are presenting a couple of life-changing trips from Atlas Obscura that capture their adventurous and curious spirit. This is the beachy island graves. Way, way up north, far in the Canadian Arctic. There's a lonely wind-swept island. No trees, nothing just pebble beats, backed by mountains. Even in summer, it can be well below freezing on this island.
因此，为了让我有足够的时间进行那场改变人生的旅行，我们带来几场来自 Atlas Obscura 的、体现其冒险和求知精神的改变人生的旅行。这就是海滩岛之墓。在极北的加拿大北极地区深处。有一个孤独、饱经风霜的岛屿。没有树木，只有鹅卵石海滩，背靠群山。即使在夏天，这个岛上的气温也可能远低于冰点。
Cheats of ice float by in the bay, a crisp wind whips across its pebble beaches, and there are no signs of life. Out here, standing alone on this rock, are four simple wooden headstones. These graves are the remnants of one of the most infamous Arctic expeditions of all time. I'm Dylan Thurus and this is Atlas Obscura, an exploration of the world's strange, incredible, and wondrous places. In this two-part series, we are going to venture out towards those frozen graves, following two groups of adventurers, separated by more than 170 years, and will play witness to the disasters that befell them all. They've all been there. Yeah, yeah, so I had a great time.
海湾里漂浮着冰块，凛冽的寒风刮过鹅卵石海滩，看不到任何生命的迹象。在这里，孤零零地矗立在这块岩石上的，是四块简单的木制墓碑。这些坟墓是有史以来最声名狼藉的北极探险活动之一的遗迹。我是迪兰·瑟鲁斯，这是 Atlas Obscura，一次对世界上奇异、不可思议和奇妙之地的探索。在这个两部分组成的系列中，我们将冒险前往那些冰冻的坟墓，跟随两组相隔 170 多年的冒险家，见证降临在他们所有人身上的灾难。他们都去过那里。是的，是的，所以我玩得很开心。
Iron Man in wooden ships. A description of heroism never more apt is when applied to those who brave the Arctic. I have to admit that I am a sucker for true life adventure stories. The extraordinary tales, the human spirit against unforgiving odds, I kinda eat it up. My bookshelf is embarrassingly full of these kinds of stories, and included among them, of course, is one of the classics, one of the epics, the story of the Franklin Expedition. Sir John Franklin was at 59, a veteran of two Oberlin expeditions in the North American Army. On the morning of May 19, 1845, Captain John Franklin said goodbye to his wife, Lady Jane Franklin, and stepped aboard his new ship.
木船上的铁血硬汉。对那些勇敢面对北极的人来说，英雄主义的赞誉再贴切不过了。我必须承认，我是一个真人真事冒险故事的迷。那些非凡的传奇，人类精神对抗残酷的逆境，我简直爱不释手。我的书架上尴尬地塞满了这类故事，其中当然包括经典之作、史诗之作——富兰克林探险的故事。约翰·富兰克林爵士当时 59 岁，是北美陆军两次奥伯林探险的老兵。1845 年 5 月 19 日清晨，约翰·富兰克林船长向妻子简·富兰克林夫人告别，踏上了他的新船。
This was the beginning of his fourth Arctic mission. He already had a reputation for being tough. His nickname in the press was the man who ate his boots, because during one of his previous archite expeditions, Venus crew had survived by eating like in and their own boot leather. At nearly 60 years old, Franklin was embarking on one more mission, one that he knew would define him. Franklin was attempting the Victorian era's version of the moonshot. Franklin was going to try and chart the Northwest passage.
这是他第四次北极任务的开始。他已经以硬汉著称。他在媒体上的绰号是“吃靴子的人”，因为在他先前的北极探险中，他的船员曾靠吃地衣和他们自己的靴子皮活了下来。将近 60 岁高龄的富兰克林即将开始又一次任务，他知道这将定义他的一生。富兰克林正在尝试维多利亚时代版本的登月计划。富兰克林要试着绘制西北航道的地图。
Finding the passage was all about money, about trade. European countries had wanted a faster route to Asia so that they could do more exporting. And the expeditions to find this trade route date back to 1497. The voyage meant sailing up and over North America through the incredible expanse of Arctic ice in order to ultimately reach the other side, the Pacific Ocean.
寻找这条航道完全是为了金钱、为了贸易。欧洲国家一直想要一条通往亚洲的更快捷路线，以便进行更多的出口。寻找这条贸易路线的航海活动可以追溯到 1497 年。这次航行意味着向北穿过北美，穿过令人难以置信的广阔北极冰层，最终到达另一侧——太平洋。
And even as the route lost its lustre as an economic possibility, the British stayed obsessed with charting it. By the time Franklin said sail in 1845, many had tried, failed, and died. failed and died. The two ships on the expedition, the HMS Arabis and the HMS Terror, had been reinforced to withstand the ice, and they were being sailed by an experienced crew of 134 sailors and officers. They even had a monkey on board named Jacko, but most of all they had lots and lots of food. 36,000 pounds of biscuits, 32,000 pounds of salted beef, 8,000 tins of preserved meat, they had a thousand pounds of just mustard and 3600 gallons of booze. It was enough food to last every sailor for three years.
尽管这条路线作为经济可能性的光芒已经黯淡，但英国人仍然痴迷于绘制它的地图。当富兰克林于 1845 年起航时，许多人已经尝试过、失败过并死去了。失败并死去了。探险队的这两艘船，“埃里伯斯号”和“惊恐号”，经过加固以抵御冰层，由 134 名经验丰富的船员和军官组成的船员队伍驾驶。他们船上甚至还有一只名叫杰科的猴子，但最重要的是，他们有大量大量的食物。36,000 磅饼干，32,000 磅咸牛肉，8,000 罐保存的肉，他们有一千磅纯芥末和 3600 加仑烈酒。这些食物足够每个船员吃三年。
When did you decide to go to the Arctic? What kind of incited you to want to take that trip? You know, I have no idea. Other than I like adventures, I was interested in the Franksville expedition. That's John Stewart. And in 2018, 173 years after the Franklin Expedition sailed, John Stewart, a thunder-be-Canada, climbed onto a little zodiac kind of inflatable boat, and motored out to a large cruise ship floating in the Arctic Bay. Oh, good. Yeah, I know, I know. At 91 years old, John Stewart was almost certainly the oldest passenger on the expedition.
你是什么时候决定去北极的？是什么促使你想进行那次旅行？你知道的，我不知道。除了我喜欢冒险，我对富兰克林探险很感兴趣。那是约翰·斯图尔特。2018 年，即富兰克林探险起航 173 年后，来自加拿大桑德贝的约翰·斯图尔特爬上了一艘小型橡皮艇，向停泊在北极海湾的一艘大型游轮驶去。哦，太好了。是的，我知道，我知道。91 岁高龄的约翰·斯图尔特几乎可以肯定是这次探险中最年长的乘客。
Yeah, well, I know I'm not one to go and sit in the beach down the floor. I like to follow history if I can. This ship, John, was boarding, was called the academic Iofi, and it was part of an Arctic tourist cruise run by a company called One Oceans, and sailed by an experienced Russian crew. The purpose of the cruise was to follow in Franklin's footsteps. To bring Franklin obsessed travelers one step closer to the object
是的，嗯，我知道我不是那种去海滩坐着的人。如果可以的话，我喜欢追随历史。约翰登上的这艘船名叫“阿卡迪亚·约菲号”，是一艘由一家名为“同一海洋”的公司运营的北极旅游游轮，由经验丰富的俄罗斯船员驾驶。这次游轮的目的是追随富兰克林的足迹。让沉迷于富兰克林的旅行者更接近他们历史迷恋的目标。
of their historical fascination. And the ship, the Iofi, was carrying a total of 126 people just about the size of Franklin's original crew. Although to be fair, the crew's expedition at John Stewart was on was a little bit cushier than Franklin's. Meals were served via a buffet line, and there were optional yoga classes.
这艘“约菲号”船上总共载有 126 人，大小几乎和富兰克林最初的船员队伍一样。尽管平心而论，约翰·斯图尔特参加的那次船员探险比富兰克林的要舒适一些。饭菜是通过自助餐形式提供的，还有可选的瑜伽课程。
John had opted for the cheaper shared bunk option. So I shared a cabin with somebody I had never met before, and I was shown to my cabin. I was the old-me person there, but eventually this young, good, lucky, inspired fellow stepped in and nearer, nearer, but me. And that fellow was me. I think we both hit it off pretty well at a very short period of time. I think we became good friends.
约翰选择了较便宜的共享铺位选项。所以我和一个我从未见过的人共用一个舱位，然后我被带到了我的舱位。我是那里年纪最大的人，但最终这个年轻、善良、幸运、受启发的家伙走了进来，走近我，靠近我。那个家伙就是我。我想我们在很短的时间内相处得很好。我想我们成了好朋友。
That's right. That's right. that's right. I was there as part of an Atlas Obscura trip, helping to make sure our travelers got what they needed. But John wasn't actually one of our Atlas Obscura travelers. He was just my delightful, unexpected, 91-year-old bunkmate. But that first night, John and I stayed up talking.
没错。没错。没错。我在那里是作为 Atlas Obscura 旅行的一部分，帮助确保我们的旅行者得到他们需要的东西。但约翰实际上并不是我们的 Atlas Obscura 旅行者之一。他只是我愉快、意想不到的 91 岁室友。但在那个第一晚，我和约翰熬夜聊天。
And he told me all about his wife and their three sons. Mara Friar won, they were young. We did a lot of canoeing around here, great canoe country up here. But they were quite adventurous trips and I really enjoyed them too. He told me all about his adventures and about how he'd been traveling alone more
他跟我讲了他的妻子和他们的三个儿子。玛拉·弗赖尔赢了，当时他们还很年轻。我们在附近划了很多独木舟，这里是很棒的独木舟之乡。但这些都是相当冒险的旅行，我也真的很喜欢它们。他跟我讲了他的所有冒险经历，以及自从他妻子去世后他是如何独自旅行更多的。
since his wife passed away. And even how just a short time before our trip, he'd actually lost one of his three sons in a biking accident. It's a sad thing, but it's life, he can't really think about it. We had some wonderful times together and almost every year we went on some major holiday somewhere. That evening, I made a note to myself. John and I were going to stick together on this trip. He was the hardiest 91-year-old I had ever met. But I figured we could both use a good crewmate.
甚至在我们旅行前不久，他在一次自行车事故中失去了三个儿子中的一个。这是一件悲伤的事情，但这就是生活，你不能总是去想它。我们曾有过一些美好的时光，几乎每年我们都会去某个地方度一个大假。那天晚上，我在心里做了一个记录。我和约翰这次旅行要形影不离。他是我见过的最坚强的 91 岁老人。但我盘算着我们俩都需要一个好的船友。
both use a good grooming. On July 6, 1845, Captain John Franklin wrote home from the whalefish islands just off the coast of Greenland. It was a letter to his wife and daughter, telling them not to worry, even if it was gone for many years. Part of the plan was for the Franklin expedition to spend multiple winters in the Arctic, and the ship was provisioned to last that long.
都用一个好同伴。1845 年 7 月 6 日，约翰·富兰克林船长从格陵兰岛海岸附近的鲸鱼鱼群岛写信回家。这是写给他的妻子和女儿的信，告诉他们不要担心，即使离开很多年也是如此。计划的一部分是让富兰克林探险队在北极度过多个冬天，船上备有足够维持那么长时间的物资。
As the Franklin expedition left the coast of Greenland, one of Franklin's crew drew a pencil sketch of the Greenland Bay, a lovely image of a single ship, floating alone surrounded by ice and rock. And with that, the crew began to sail up and over the very top of the globe. Of course, Franklin and his crew were not actually the first explorers to make it this far into the Northwest passage, and the idea that they could even discover it was wrong. The Arctic waterways running from Greenland to Alaska
当富兰克林探险队离开格陵兰岛海岸时，富兰克林的一名船员画了一幅格陵兰海湾的铅笔素描，这是一幅可爱的画面：一艘孤零零的船，漂浮在周围都是冰块和岩石的中间。就这样，船员们开始向北驶过地球的最顶端。当然，富兰克林和他的船员并不是第一批深入西北航道的探险家，他们甚至能发现它的想法是错误的。从格陵兰岛延伸到阿拉斯加的北极水道
had already been home to Arctic and Inuit peoples for over 4,000 years. By the time Franklin came to find it, the Northwest passage had been thoroughly explored by Inuit tribes as they hunted, fished, and settled across thousands of miles of Arctic coastline. Then as Franklin's expedition had a deeper and deeper into the Arctic, the Inuit watched from afar, observing his progress through the passage, and into the dangers that they
4000 多年来一直是北极和因纽特人的人民的家园。当富兰克林来寻找它时，西北航道已经被因纽特部落在数千英里的北极海岸线上狩猎、捕鱼和定居时彻底探索过了。然后，随着富兰克林探险队越来越深入北极，因纽特人在远处观看，观察他在航道上的进展，以及进入他们早已知道的危险之中。
already knew. Here on Beach Island, at the upper reaches of the passage, are the graves of three ordinary sailors doomed by extraordinary circumstances. During the first winter in the Arctic, the Franklin expedition hit an impasse, a frozen expanse of ice that they couldn't sail through, so they tried to turn around, but they were stuck. The way back had frozen solid.
在这里，在航道最上游的比奇岛上，长眠着三名因极端环境而注定走向毁灭的普通水手。在北极的第一个冬天，富兰克林探险队遇到了僵局，一片他们无法航行的冰冻冰原，所以他们试图掉头，但他们被困住了。回头的路已经冻得结结实实。
That in and of itself wasn't the end of the world. They were in the Arctic. It was full of ice and they had expected something like this to happen, so they settled in for the first winter. And during that winter, the first touch of death visited the expedition. Three men, 20-year-old John Torrington, 32-year-old William Brain, and 25-year-old John Hartnell all died from some combination of pneumonia, malnourishment, zinc deficiency, and lead poisoning. In fact, they may well have been ill when they first boarded the ship.
这本身并不是世界末日。他们身处北极。那里到处都是冰，他们也预料到会发生类似的事情，于是他们在那里安顿下来过第一个冬天。就在那个冬天，死神第一次造访了探险队。三名男子——20 岁的约翰·托灵顿、32 岁的威廉·布莱恩和 25 岁的约翰·哈特内尔——死于肺炎、营养不良、锌缺乏和铅中毒的某种组合。事实上，他们刚登船时可能就已经生病了。
When he died, 20-year-old John Torrington only weighed 85 pounds. All three were buried on beachy island. The very graves, John and I, were sailing off to sea. On the second day aboard the academic afty, John and I woke up, and along with all the other new passengers, we went into what was called the mudroom, where we practiced putting on our fowel weather gear. Basically just huge waterproof waiters and boots. The ocean water temperature was around 28 degrees or just below freezing so these weren't going to do you much good if you actually fell into the water but they were meant to keep you from getting soaked
去世时，20 岁的约翰·托灵顿体重只有 85 磅。三人都埋葬在比奇岛上。正是约翰和我正要乘船前往的那些坟墓。在登上“阿卡迪亚·约菲号”的第二天，约翰和我醒来，和其他所有新乘客一起，走进了一个叫作泥帽间的地方，我们在那里练习穿防风雨装备。基本上就是巨大的防水涉水裤和靴子。海水温度约为 28 度，刚到冰点以下，所以如果你真的落水，这些东西起不了多大作用，但它们是为了防止你在乘坐小橡皮艇时被浸湿。
when you went out on one of the little zodiac boats. After that we clomped our way up onto the deck where we all got trained in the use of the lifeboats. As we listened to the instructions, we stood along the bow of the ship and looked out at this new landscape in front of us. The wind was overpowering. The Arctic Ocean lapped against bare rocks. There are no trees, just water and stone. To my unfamiliar eyes, the landscape felt inhospitable and barren. Just about done with our introductory training, we all filed down below to watch a PowerPoint about how to avoid getting eaten by polar bears.
之后，我们踩着沉重的脚步来到甲板上，在那里我们都接受了救生艇使用的培训。当我们听取说明时，我们站在船头，望着眼前的这片新地貌。风大得惊人。北极海拍打着光秃秃的岩石。没有树木，只有水和石头。在我这个生疏的眼睛看来，这片地貌显得荒凉而贫瘠。刚完成入门培训，我们便排队下到底层，观看一个关于如何避免被北极熊吃掉的 PPT。
And I remember the rumors dark showing must have been showing PowerPoints, but as we were sitting there listening to this, all of a sudden there was a huge crash. I can still hear it. It's just like somebody was beating a oil drum with steel wires, and then we were throwing forward off our chairs. And obviously we hit something, and I think you could say if we say we were going to eat a rock at a hard place because we had hit a rock. We were all sent to our cabins and told the stay there.
我记得那些传言暗中展示的一定是 PPT，但正当我们坐在那里听着这些时，突然传出了一声巨响。我至今仍能听到。就像有人用钢丝敲打油桶一样，然后我们被从椅子上向前抛了出去。很显然我们撞到了什么东西，我想如果你说我们陷入了进退维谷的境地，那是对的，因为我们撞到了一块岩石。我们都被送回各自的船舱，并被告知待在里面。
The ship was listing at an angle that made it hard to walk. And as John and I slowly made our way back up the stairs, we saw the Russian crew, which up until this point, we hadn't seen that much of, now running all over the place, shouting in Russian, all wearing their life jackets. And the ship continued to sway at this nauseating angle. John and I made it back to our room, and we put on the foul weathered gear we had just been trained to use.
船以一种让人难以行走的角度倾斜着。当我和约翰慢慢沿着楼梯往回走时，我们看到俄罗斯船员——在此之前我们没怎么见过他们——现在正到处跑，用俄语大喊大叫，都穿着救生衣。船继续以这个令人作呕的角度摇晃着。我和约翰回到了我们的房间，我们穿上了刚接受过培训如何使用的防风雨装备。
Ready, potentially, to go back out on deck and lower those lifeboats down into the water. We just had to see our little tour water. And then we just sat, awaiting further instructions, waiting to hear whether we needed to abandon ship. Anyway, it's fun being with you, don't you? You too, John. Take care, don't forget. We were keeping our spirits high, but truth be told, I was pretty nervous.
随时准备着重新回到甲板上，把那些救生艇降到水中。我们只需要看看我们的导游水域。然后我们只是坐着，等待进一步的指示，等待听到我们是否需要弃船。不管怎样，和你在一起很有趣，不是吗？你也是，约翰。保重，别忘了。我们保持着高昂的士气，但说实话，我相当紧张。
Now I can't remember his name, I can only think of Franklin. He's the wrong one to think of Franklin. We don't want to think of Franklin, we want to think of Robinson. Robinson, Perry would be okay. Shackleton. Shackleton. Yeah. Pray for Shackleton, Franklin. I'm afraid for shackles. And frankly, I'm afraid for shackles.
现在我想不起他的名字，我只能想到富兰克林。想到富兰克林是不对的。我们不想想到富兰克林，我们想想到罗宾逊。罗宾逊，佩里也可以。沙克尔顿。沙克尔顿。是的。为沙克尔顿祈祷，富兰克林。我为沙克尔顿担心。坦白说，我为沙克尔顿担心。
As my 91-year-old bunkmate and I sat in our cabin, we were very much aware that we and John Franklin were exploring the same Arctic. The water and rocks outside my windows were just like what Franklin had sailed past himself. And everyone on my boat, including us, knew how the Franklin expedition had ended. So, yeah, we're in the heart and we run the ship around. We're like literally stuck on a rock. It's a very exciting journey. Too probably too exciting for everybody here.
当我和我 91 岁的室友坐在船舱里时，我们非常清楚，我们和约翰·富兰克林正在探索同一个北极。我窗外的水和岩石就像富兰克林自己曾经航行经过的一模一样。我船上的每个人，包括我们两个，都知道富兰克林探险队的结局。所以，是的，我们在核心部位，我们把船撞了。我们字面意义上卡在了一块岩石上。这是一次非常刺激的旅程。对这里的每个人来说可能太刺激了。
How are we gonna give a wish to you? Sometime in the early 1900s, in the northern islands of the Canadian Arctic, an innuid girl named Humahawk was out with her father walking across the ice and rocks. She was about seven or eight at the time and Humahawk and her father were out looking for driftwood when something bright caught her eye. A glint of light, the sun reflecting off of an eye metal object. And they are laying in the snow of the vast Arctic plain. She found a single engraved dinner knife. It was a relic of a long-lost crew and one key in unlocking the fate of the Franklin expedition.
我们怎么能给你一个愿望呢？大约在 20 世纪初，在加拿大北极地区的北部岛屿上，一个名叫乌玛霍克的因纽特女孩和她的父亲一起在冰块和岩石间漫步。当时她大约七八岁，乌玛霍克和父亲正在寻找浮木，这时有什么闪亮的东西吸引了她的眼光。一闪光芒，太阳反射在一个金属物体上。它们躺在广阔北极平原的雪地里。她发现了一把刻字的晚餐刀。这是一支早已消失的船员的遗物，也是解开富兰克林探险队命运的一把关键钥匙。
There was a huge bump. This is about 15-20 minutes after the big bump. And it feels like the ship is trying to pull itself off or off. They said they said, yeah, we've grounded. We've actually grounded the ship. So you can feel most of them. That's John Stewart of Thunder Bay, Canada.
发生了一次巨大的撞击。这大约是大撞击后 15-20 分钟。感觉船正试图把自己从岩石上拉开。他们说，他们说，是的，我们搁浅了。我们真的让船搁浅了。所以你能感觉到大部分。那是来自加拿大安大略省桑德贝的约翰·斯图尔特。
He was my 91-year-old bunkmate on the academic Iofi, an Arctic cruise ship that was following in the path of the Franklin expedition. The Franklin expedition was a famous Arctic voyage that left in 1845 to chart the Northwest passage, but instead found themselves stuck in the ice. And on my trip, to follow in the footsteps of an Arctic voyage where things had gone incredibly wrong. Things had gone incredibly wrong. As John said about 15 minutes earlier, our cruise ship had hit a rock with an enormous crash,
他是我在“阿卡迪亚·约菲号”上的 91 岁室友，“阿卡迪亚·约菲号”是一艘沿着富兰克林探险路线行驶的北极游轮。富兰克林探险是 1845 年出发绘制西北航道地图的一场著名北极航行，但最终发现自己被困在冰中。而在我的旅行中，去追随一场事情发生极其糟糕错误的北极航行的足迹。事情发生极其糟糕错误。正如约翰大约 15 分钟前所说，我们的游轮伴随着一声巨响撞上了一块岩石，
throwing people to the ground. Outside on the deck you could hear the Arctic wind absolutely howling. The Russian crew was running around with their life jackets already on, shouting in Russian. John and I sat in our cabin waiting. We've been told of this time to get in for our heavy gear, and that's about where we are right now, just waiting for our next set of instructions. Inside, people were beginning to mill about. The crews had shut the bar down, but the buffet line was still operating. Inside, people were beginning to mill about. The crews had shut the bar down, but the buffet line was still operating.
把人们摔倒在地。外面甲板上，你可以听到北极风在绝对呼啸。俄罗斯船员穿着已经穿好的救生衣跑来跑去，用俄语大喊大叫。约翰和我坐在船舱里等待。我们被告知这时候要穿上厚重的装备，这就是我们现在的状态，只是在等待下一组指示。里面的人开始四处闲逛。船员们关了酒吧，但自助餐仍在运营。里面的人开始四处闲逛。船员们关了酒吧，但自助餐仍在运营。
It had to be the most awkward, nervous buffet I have ever been a part of. And wherever you were on the ship, inside or out, you could hear and feel the engines grinding as they struggled to pull us off this rock. At least until they shut them down, and the ship went quiet. I can remember sitting in the cabin waiting to be told what we're gonna do. I don't think anybody panicked that I saw.
这一定是我经历过的最尴尬、最紧张的自助餐了。无论你在船上的哪个地方，里面还是外面，你都能听到并感觉到发动机在努力把我们从这块岩石上拉下来时发出的刺耳摩擦声。至少直到它们关闭发动机，船归于平静。我记得坐在船舱里等待被告知我们要做什么。据我所见，没有人恐慌。
Everybody was calm and accepted what had happened, and I think everybody accepted their fate. happened and I think everybody accepted their fate. In September of 1847, John Franklin and his Arctic expedition had been gone for over two years. Franklin had known before he left that it would take years to get through the Arctic, and no one expected to hear from him within a year, and two years didn't seem that far out of the ordinary. But Franklin's wife, Lady Jane Franklin, she was beginning to worry. She wrote to another famous art to explore Sir John Ross and urged him onward in a rescue
每个人都很平静，接受了所发生的事情，我想每个人都接受了他们的命运。发生了，我想每个人都接受了他们的命运。1847 年 9 月，约翰·富兰克林和他的北极探险队已经离开两年多了。富兰克林在离开前就知道穿过北极需要数年时间，没有人期望能在一年内听到他的消息，而两年看起来也并不是那么不寻常。但富兰克林的妻子简·富兰克林夫人开始担心了。她写信给另一位著名的北极探险家约翰·罗斯爵士，敦促他进行救援任务。
mission. She wrote, Should it be you to rescue them from parallel death, you will have your reward? Sir John Ross, the explorer Lady Franklin was hoping would rescue her husband, had himself spent four years surviving in the Arctic, and he was a long time friend of the Franklands. In 1848, more than three years after the Franklin expedition had departed, Ross set out alongside two other expeditions, each approaching from a different angle, on the hopes of finding the Franklin expedition.
她写道：“如果由你将他们从濒死中解救出来，你将得到回报。”约翰·罗斯爵士，也就是富兰克林夫人希望用来营救她丈夫的探险家，自己曾在北极艰难求生四年，他是富兰克林一家的老朋友。1848 年，在富兰克林探险队出发三年多后，罗斯与其他两支探险队一同出发，每支队伍从不同的角度接近，怀着找到富兰克林探险队的希望。
Instead, they found nothing. Those would be the first rescue expeditions of many, many to follow, often with Lady Franklin as the motivating force behind them. The English public followed along with baited breath, finding Sir John Franklin and his lost expedition became a nationwide obsession. Lady Franklin, searching through the Arctic for her lost husband. In taverns across the country, ballads were sung of Lady Franklin's lament.
然而，他们什么也没找到。这些将是随后许多次救援探险中的第一次，通常以简·富兰克林夫人作为背后的推动力。英国公众屏住呼吸关注着，寻找约翰·富兰克林和他的失踪探险队成为了一种全国性的痴迷。简·富兰克林夫人在北极寻找她失踪的丈夫。在全国各地的酒馆里，人们唱着《简·富兰克林的哀歌》的民谣。
In 1854, nearly a decade after the Franklin expedition had first set out, and after more than a dozen rescue expeditions, one rescue mission leader, Captain Ray, returned from the Arctic with particularly grim news. He had spoken at length with the local Inuit tribes, and their stories of the expedition's fate were pretty clear. Captain Ray wrote that the unfortunate party under Sir John Franklin had met with a fate as melancholy and dreadful as it is possible to imagine.
1854 年，在富兰克林探险队首次出发近十年后，在经历了十几次救援探险之后，一位救援任务领队雷船长带着特别严峻的消息从北极归来。他与当地的因纽特部落进行了长时间的交谈，他们关于探险队命运的故事非常清晰。雷船长写道，约翰·富兰克林爵士领导的不幸队伍遭遇了可以想象到的最凄惨、最可怕的命运。
The bodies of some 30 persons were discovered on the continent. From the mutilated state of many of the corpses and the contents of their kettles, it is evident that our wretched countrymen had been driven to the last resource, cannibalism, as a means of prolonging existence. In England, this news was met with absolute refusal. No one wanted to even entertain the idea that their noble hero and his crew might have resorted to cannibalism, least of all his wife, Lady Franklin. Captain Ray, who brought back the stories from the Inuit, was defamed, and a wave of racism
在大陆上发现了大约 30 人的尸体。从许多尸体遭到毁容的状态以及他们锅里的东西来看，很明显，我们苦命的同胞已被逼到了最后的手段——人食人，以此作为延续生命的手段。在英国，这个消息遭到了绝对的拒绝。没有人愿意去想他们的崇高英雄和船员可能会诉诸人食人，尤其是他的妻子简·富兰克林夫人。带回因纽特人故事的雷船长遭到诋毁，一股种族主义浪潮
was unleashed against the Inuit. Charles Dickens referred to the stories as the vague babble of savages. But the evidence that John Franklin and his men were dead was hard to dismiss. The gravestones had already been found on beachy island, and later a note was discovered under a carn, saying that Admiral John Franklin had actually died in 1847, long before the first rescue mission had ever even departed. But even so, much remained mysterious. None of the dozens of missions to find the Franklin Expedition
向因纽特人倾泻而下。查尔斯·狄更斯将这些故事称为“野蛮人的模糊胡言乱语”。但约翰·富兰克林和他的手下已经死亡的证据很难被驳回。墓碑已经在比奇岛上被找到，后来在一个石堆下发现了一张字条，上面说约翰·富兰克林海军上将实际上死于 1847 年，远在第一次救援任务出发之前。即便如此，许多事情依然是个谜。数十次寻找富兰克林探险队的任务中，没有一次
was ever able to find out exactly where the men had gone, much less find the wreckage of the ships. Discovering that would have to wait another 170 years, and for the world to actually listen to Inuit stories. My name is Louis Comacac, I live in Joe Haven. I was born in Russia and I'm a known as a local historian. That's Louis Kamukak. Louis had been collecting Inuit stories for his whole life,
能够查明这些男人究竟去了哪里，更不用说找到船只的残骸了。发现这一点必须等待另外 170 年，并等待世界真正倾听因纽特人的故事。我叫路易斯·科马库克，我住在乔海文。我出生在俄罗斯，我是一名当地历史学家。那是路易斯·科马库克。路易斯一生都在收集因纽特人的故事，
and Humahook, that Inuit girl who found the dinner knife, the one left behind by the Franklin expedition, that was actually Louis' great-grandmother. This is from a video that McLean's a Canadian news magazine made about Louis. There was one story that my great-grandmother told me they start finding all kinds of artifacts. She said they noticed that there was a big chain going into the ocean. Her story was always in my mind, but I didn't have a clue till I started going to school. The teachers started teaching history and they started talking about the Franklin expedition. Louis' knowledge of the traditional Inuit stories,
而乌玛霍克，那个发现富兰克林探险队留下来的晚餐刀的因纽特女孩，实际上是路易斯的曾祖母。这段视频来自加拿大新闻杂志《麦克林》为路易斯制作的节目。曾祖母给我讲过这样一个故事：他们开始发现各种各样的文物。她说他们注意到有一条大链子通向海洋。她的故事一直记在我脑海里，但在我上学之前我毫无头绪。老师们开始教历史，他们开始谈论富兰克林探险。路易斯对因纽特传统故事的了解，
end of the Franklin expedition, made him a unique expert on the subject and led him to believe that he that were mentioned by Eldrush. For nearly 160 years, the wereabouts of the HMS Arabis and HMS Terror remained a mystery, but in 2014, using in-uit testimony to guide them, Louis Comaook led a team from Parks Canada to the site of the HMS Aerobes. And recorded on a map from the 1860s is the inuit name of the area where the ship was found. And translated, it reads, the boat sank here. When I heard the news about one of the ship being flown, I think it was kind of emotional for me to think about the elders
以及对富兰克林探险的了解，使他成为该主题的独特专家，并让他相信那些被埃尔德鲁什提到的人。近 160 年来，“埃里伯斯号”和“惊恐号”的下落一直是个谜，但在 2014 年，在因纽特人证词的引导下，路易斯·科马库克带领加拿大公园局的一支团队来到了“埃里伯斯号”的遗址。1860 年代的一张地图上记录了发现该船的地区的因纽特语名称。翻译过来就是：船在这里沉没。当我听到其中一艘船被发现的消息时，我认为对于我来说，想到那些我采访过的长辈们，他们一直都是对的，这是一种情绪化的时刻。
that have been interviewing, they have been right on the law. And in it all history was powerful and it was the only way that everything was passed down through generations. It was passed on through generations. Louis Cama Cook died just a couple of years after the second ship that HMS Terror was discovered. Finding it was the result of a lifetime of his work collecting Inuit stories. The Royal Canadian Geographic Society called him the last great Franklin Surgeon.
因纽特人的口述历史是强大的，它是代代相传的唯一途径。它是通过一代代人传下来的。路易斯·科马库克在第二艘船“惊恐号”被发现后仅仅几年就去世了。找到它融入了他一生收集因纽特人故事的工作。加拿大皇家地理学会称他为“最后一个伟大的富兰克林搜寻者”。
We also know more about what happened to the Franklin Expedition, all of those years stuck in the ice, thanks largely to stories from the Inuit. Franklin died early, but the rest of the sailors died a longer, slower death. One by one succumbing to scurvy, starvation, zinc deficiency, hypothermia. Some of the sailors may have lived as long as six or seven years out on the ice, but in the end none of them ever made it back home.
我们对富兰克林探险队在冰中被困那些年的遭遇有了更多了解，很大程度上要归功于因纽特人的故事。富兰克林过早离世，但其余的水手则迎来了更长、更慢的死亡。他们一个接一个地死于坏血病、饥饿、锌缺乏、低体温症。有些水手可能在冰上生活了六年或七年之久，但最终他们没有一个人能活着回家。
Over the course of a decade, almost 32 expeditions went out searching for Franklin. Though those rescue expeditions never found Franklin. They did end up doing what Franklin was unable to. They effectively charted the Northwest Passage, and it was successfully navigated by Norwegian explorer Rold Amensen in 1906. Luckily for John and I, we didn't suffer quite the same fate as Franklin.
在十年的时间里，将近 32 支探险队出发寻找富兰克林。尽管这些救援探险从未找到富兰克林。但它们最终做到了富兰克林未能做到的事情。它们有效地绘制了西北航道的地图，并由挪威探险家罗尔德·阿蒙森于 1906 年成功航行通过。幸运的是，我和约翰没有遭受和富兰克林完全一样的命运。
We were eventually rescued. It was really only 24 hours later, but it was a long 24 hours. And the real possibility of disaster had hung over all of us, just the sense that we had come to a place without really knowing how to survive there. As we took our zodiacs across the ocean and loaded onto our new ship, relief washed over everyone. It was only 8 a.m. in the morning, but the bar was open and John and I made ample use of it. It was glorious. You two John.
我们最终获救了。其实只过了 24 小时，但这漫长的 24 小时。灾难的真实可能性一直笼罩在我们所有人头顶，那种我们来到一个并不真正知道如何生存的地方的感觉。当我们坐着橡皮艇穿过海洋并登上我们新船时，如释重负的感觉涌上了每个人的心头。当时才早上 8 点，但酒吧已经开门了，我和约翰充分利用了它。这太棒了。你也是，约翰。
That was almost three years ago. almost three years ago. ... ... ... ... Calling John. So lucky he wrote down his information on an index card and then I took a picture of it.
那是将近三年前的事了。将近三年前的事了。……打电话给约翰。太幸运了，他在索引卡上写下了他的信息，然后我拍了照片。
... Hello. Hi. Is this John Stewart? It is John Stewart. Oh, my word, John. It is, okay, let me tell you. My name is Dylan and we were shipwrecked together. Yeah.
……喂。你好。是约翰·斯图尔特吗？我是约翰·斯图尔特。哦，天哪，约翰。是的，好吧，让我告诉你。我叫迪兰，我们曾一起遭遇海难。是的。
For heaven's sake, how are you doing? I'm doing fine. How are you doing? Well, I'm doing okay. I picked over to the 93 the other day. And... When I was writing? Well, I'm doing okay. I picked over to the 93th the other day. When I was writing this story, I knew I needed to give John a call. When I talked to him, what I found out was that wasn't John's last trip. Franklin never made it to beach island and back, and I never even made it to beach island.
天哪，你最近怎么样？我挺好的。你怎么样？嗯，我挺好的。前几天我刚过了 93 岁生日。而且……当我写的时候？嗯，我挺好的。前几天我刚过了 93 岁生日。当我写这个故事时，我知道我需要给约翰打个电话。当我跟他谈话时，我发现那并不是约翰的最后一次旅行。富兰克林从未往返比奇岛，而我甚至从未到达过比奇岛。
But you know who did? I took the next cruise. You went back out. You went back out on another ship. Yeah, yeah. So I had a great time. But I was hoping that you would be there. We'd be gathered mates again.
但你知道谁去了吗？我坐了下一艘游轮。你又回去了。你坐另一艘船又回去了。是的，所以我玩得很开心。但我希望你在那里。我们再次成为室友。
I would have loved that. I wished, oh, that would have been great. Well, I'm so glad to hear that you made it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We were up above the Arctic surefl, actually. Then we went ashore, landed at the gray site. There it just for wooden slab headstones there, with a brass plaque on each one.
我会很喜欢那样。我希望，哦，那会很棒。很高兴听到你成功了。是的，是的，是的。我们实际上在北极圈上方。然后我们上岸，在墓地登陆。那里只有四块木质平板墓碑，每个上面都有一个黄铜牌匾。
At 93, you've lived quite a full life. Do you have any advice for, you know, I'm, I'm 38 now, which to me feels like well on in my years. I've got two young kids. Do you have any advice for me or anyone else? I always be kind to people, to forgive, have purpose in life, and friends are one of your most important assets, cherish them. in your most important asset,
93 岁高龄，你过着相当充实的生活。你对……你知道的，我现在 38 岁，对我来说这感觉已经是我人生的后期了。我有两个年幼的孩子。你对我和其他任何人有什么建议吗？总是对人友善，去原谅，生活中要有目标，朋友是你最重要的财富之一，要珍惜他们。你最宝贵的财富，
cherished boom. I have a memory of John that I will never forget, that last time at the bar, when the two of us were together in person, having just been rescued from a stranded ship, drinking a beer at eight in the morning, and in the background, someone put on a famous song about Franklin. People in the bar began singing along. Frank Lentzberg came over the ghost of the sea. Whether we meant two or not, we had truly gotten to experience a tiny bit of what it felt like to be out on the Franklin Expedition.
要珍惜啊。我对约翰有一个永远不会忘记的记忆，那就是最后一次在酒吧里，我们俩在一起，刚刚从搁浅的船上被救出来，早上八点喝着啤酒，在背景音乐中，有人放了一首关于富兰克林的著名歌曲。酒吧里的人们开始跟着唱。富兰克林冰山穿过了海的幽灵。不管我们是不是有意的，我们确实真正体验了一点点身处富兰克林探险队的感觉。
To follow our curiosity, to embark in the spirit of adventure and to sail out in Franklin's path. To take one last trip. more light through our lands, a white and savage, and make a northwest passage to the sea. More Atlas Obscura, after this. Here again is Atlas Obscura on 99% Invisible. In the late 1980s, a suitcase arrived at a warehouse in Scottsboro, Alabama. That wasn't so unusual. A lot of suitcases showed up at this particular warehouse. But inside this bag was something special. They opened this cage and this troll face is staring back at you.
追随我们的好奇心，怀着冒险精神启航，沿着富兰克林的道路航行。进行最后一次旅行。更多的光穿过我们的土地，一片白色而野蛮的土地，开辟一条通往大海的西北航道。更多 Atlas Obscura，广告之后见。这里依然是 99% Invisible 带来的 Atlas Obscura。在 20 世纪 80 年代末，一个手提箱抵达了阿拉巴马州斯科茨伯勒的一个仓库。这并不那么寻常。许多手提箱都会出现在这个特定的仓库里。但这个包里有特殊的东西。他们打开这个笼子，这个巨魔脸正盯着你。
A four-foot tall goblin puppet with a giant head, a huge nose, and piercing blue eyes. I'm Hoggle. Who are you? Inside the bag was the real original Hoggled doll, this beloved character from the Jim Henson movie Labrith. I get tickled every time I think about how funny and astonishing that must have been.
一个四英尺高的妖精木偶，有着一个巨大的头、一个巨大的鼻子和一双锐利的蓝眼睛。我是霍格尔。你是谁？包里是真正的原版霍格尔玩偶，这个来自吉姆·汉森电影《魔幻迷宫》的深受喜爱的角色。每当我想象那一定有多有趣和惊人时，我都会觉得好笑。
We were just amazed at, we have Hoggled. If you lose your luggage while traveling, you're probably going to get it back. 99.5% of lost bags ultimately make their way back to their owners. But once in a while, that other 0.5%, bags slip through the cracks. And when that happens, airlines will hang on to the luggage for 90 days. They do their best to reunite bag and owner, but after that 90 days, the bag legally becomes the airline's property. And that is when the Unclaimed Baggage Center steps in.
我们简直惊呆了，我们拥有了霍格尔。如果你在旅行中丢失了行李，你很可能会把它找回来。99.5% 的丢失行李最终都会回到它们的主人手中。但偶尔，那另外的 0.5%，行李会从缝隙中漏掉。当这种情况发生时，航空公司会保留行李 90 天。他们尽最大努力让行李和失主团聚，但在那 90 天之后，行李在法律上就成了航空公司的财产。这就是无主行李中心介入的时候。
The Unclaimed Baggage Center buys orphan bags from the airlines, and then either donates, recycles, or resells their contents. And they've got contracts with all the domestic airlines and they go and load up these lost bags on semis at the airport and then drive them all the way back to Scottsboro. I attract just back to our building and we unload those two cases and we have a team of what we call openers and we'lled those two cases, and we have a team of what we call openers that will open the two cases. This is Jennifer Kretner, and she's been working at Unclaimed baggage
无主行李中心从航空公司购买无人认领的行李，然后捐赠、回收或转售它们的内容物。他们与所有国内航空公司都有合同，他们去机场把这些丢失的行李装上半挂车，然后一路开回斯科茨伯勒。我直接把行李拉回我们的建筑，我们卸下那些箱子，我们有一支由我们称之为开箱员的人组成的团队，我们会卸下那些箱子，我们有一支由我们称之为开箱员的人组成的团队，负责打开这些箱子。这是詹妮弗·克雷特纳，她在无主行李中心工作
for more than 20 years, since she was just five days out of high school. And they go through each suitcase to figure out, you know, does the Southam need to be sold? Does the Southam need to be cleaned? Does the Southam need to be recycled? Or does the Southam need to be cleaned? Does the Sada need to be recycled? Or does the Sada need to be donated? Personally, I would love to spend a day being a bag opener.
已经超过 20 年了，从她高中毕业仅仅五天后就开始了。他们检查每个手提箱以弄清楚，你知道的，这些东西需要出售吗？这些东西需要清洗吗？这些东西需要回收吗？或者这些东西需要清洗吗？这些东西需要回收吗？或者这些东西需要捐赠吗？就个人而言，我很乐意花一天时间当一名开箱员。
Each bag would be like a little Christmas morning. Like, what is in there? What's inside the next one? Although, that said, more than once, bag openers have opened up a suitcase and found a live rattlesnake inside. Another time, they found an entire bare-pelt, packed in salt, and still in the middle of the curing process.
每个包都像圣诞节的早晨一样。比如，里面有什么？下一个里面是什么？话虽如此，不止一次，开箱员打开手提箱，发现里面有一条活的响尾蛇。还有一次，他们发现了一整张熊皮，用盐包裹着，仍然处于硝制过程中。
Smell kind of gave it away. So, there are some hazards to the job, but there are also some thrills. We've had aluminum fire suits. We've had two full suits of armor. The most expensive thing that we've ever sold was actually a mint platinum presidential Rolex. It retailed for $64,000.
气味有点暴露了它。所以，这份工作有一些危险，但也有一些刺激。我们有过铝制消防服。我们有过两套完整的盔甲。我们卖过的最贵的东西实际上是一块薄荷品相的白金总统劳力士。它的零售价为 64,000 美元。
We sold it in our store to a gentleman that shopped for this about one month. And he purchased it for $32,000. We sold it in our store to a gentleman that shopped to this about one a month and he purchased it for $32,000. The finer jewelry that winds up at Unclaimed Baggage gets appraised and I'll just say this is why I'm a carry-on only kind of guy. One of the coolest things that we have gotten in in my time here was a 40-karat and natural raw in-rolled. And we found that in the toe of a sock rolled up in the corner of a suitcase. I mean, totally interesting me.
我们在店里把它卖给了一位大约每个月来买一次东西的绅士。他以 32,000 美元的价格买下了它。我们在店里把它卖给了一位大约每个月来买一次东西的绅士，他以 32,000 美元的价格买下了它。最终落脚在无主行李中心的精美珠宝会经过估价，我只想说，这就是为什么我只带随身行李的原因。我在我这里工作期间得到的最高酷的东西之一是一块 40 克拉的天然原石。我们在一个手提箱角落里卷着的一只袜子的脚趾里找到了它。我的意思是，这真的让我很感兴趣。
He wouldn't ever think something that's for $30,000, would just be in the toe of a sock, tossed in with a dirty laundry, but that's exactly how we found it. Finding an emerald in someone's dirty laundry is exciting, but for the vast majority of the time, it's just dirty laundry. Lots and lots and lots of dirty laundry. Every bag tells a story. So some of these bags were all in their range of the trip and some of the
他绝不会想到，价值3万美元的东西会塞在袜子里，和脏衣服扔在一起，但我们就是这样找到它的。在某人的脏衣服里找到一块祖母绿宝石令人兴奋，但在绝大多数情况下，那只是脏衣服。数不清的脏衣服。每个袋子都讲述着一个故事。其中一些袋子是他们旅行时的全部行李，另一些则是
bags were coming home from the trips. You can imagine, it's not as glamorous as one might think, but it is very interesting. In fact, there is so much dirty laundry that unclaimed baggage has its own laundry facility. They process over 50,000 items every month. That's the biggest straw cleaning service in the state of Alabama. As a matter of fact, that's more than most laundry mats processed in an entire year. Instead, that happens right here. It's thoughts for you. The laundry gets washed and the electronics are sent away to be wiped of their previous owner's data. And yes, there are a lot, a lot of electronics, headphones, laptops, iPads. So easy to leave in those seatback pockets.
从旅行中带回家的袋子。你可以想象，这并不像人们想象的那样光鲜亮丽，但非常有趣。事实上，无主行李中心的脏衣服多到它拥有自己的洗衣设施。他们每个月处理超过5万件物品。那是阿拉巴马州最大的服装清洗服务。事实上，这比大多数自助洗衣店一整年处理的还要多。相反，这一切就发生在这里。这是为你准备的。衣物清洗完毕后，电子产品将被送去清除前主人的数据。是的，这里有非常多的电子产品，耳机、笔记本电脑、iPad。太容易落在那些座椅背后的口袋里了。
Finally, everything is ready for its second life. If something doesn't get recycled or donated, it goes out to the store shelves and attention to all bargain hunters out there. Most items in the store are resold for about 20 to 80% off their retail price. There are roughly 45,000 flights every day in the store are resold for about 20 to 80% off their retail price. There are roughly 45,000 flights every day in the United States. So of the bags that get lost each day, even if only half of one percent of those bags
最后，一切都为它们的第二生命做好了准备。如果某些东西没有被回收或捐赠，它就会摆上商店的货架，请注意所有喜欢讨价还价的人。店里的绝大多数商品以其零售价大约20%到80%的折扣转售。美国每天大约有45,000个航班。因此，在每天丢失的行李中，即使只有百分之零点五的行李
are truly lost, it adds up quick. Unclaimed baggage center stocks anywhere from 5,000 to 7,000 new items every single day. Today, Unclaimed Baggage Center is this huge sprawling place. It's bigger than a city block, but it started much much smaller. In 1970, Doyle Owens was working part-time as an insurance salesman in Scottsboro when he got a call from a friend who worked for a bus company in Washington, DC. The Frento Doyle about a unique problem he had. He had too many pieces of lost luggage that were just piling up. I borrowed my dad's pickup truck and $300 as one of the first load went to Washington, DC, and picked up the bag. Doyle died in 2016 and this is footage from an oral history made by Unclaimed Baggage.
真正永久丢失，加起来也是一个庞大的数字。无主行李中心每天库存5,000到7,000件新物品。如今，无主行李中心是一个庞大而延伸的场所。它比一个城市街区还要大，但它起步时要小得多。1970年，多伊尔·欧文斯（Doyle Owens）在斯科茨伯勒做兼职保险推销员时，接到了一位在华盛顿特区一家巴士公司工作的朋​​友的电话。这位朋友向多伊尔谈起了一个独特的麻烦。他有太多积压如山的失物行李。我借了我爸爸的皮卡车和300美元，作为运送到华盛顿特区的第一批货物之一，把行李取了回来。多伊尔于2016年去世，这是无主行李中心制作的口述历史片段。
When we look like J.D. Clampage, Clannlin' coming back down from Washington, they see it the Alabama. When Doyle got back to Scottsboro with his very first luggage haul, he set up a handful of card tables in an old rented house and he ran an ad in the local paper. He planned to be open for just two days, but by the end of the first day, he was already completely sold out. And that's when Doyle knew he was on to something. A few years later, Doyle landed his first contract with an airline company,
当我们看起来像J.D.克兰佩奇（J.D. Clampage）一样，从华盛顿返回时，他们看到了阿拉巴马州。当多伊尔带着他第一批行李战利品回到斯科茨伯勒时，他在一栋租来的老房子里摆了几张卡片桌，并在当地报纸上登了广告。他原本计划只营业两天，但在第一天结束时，就已经完全售罄了。就在那时，多伊尔知道他找到了商机。几年后，多伊尔拿下了他与一 家航空公司的第一份合同，
and eventually locked in contracts with other domestic carriers. He quit his insurance job and the business popped along steadily. But then, in 1995, a little talk show picked up the story. Did you see a gold necklace that's about... Right. Actually, I saw... But I lost it in Newark airport five years ago. Right.
并最终锁定了与其他国内航空公司的合同。他辞去了保险工作，生意稳步发展。但随后，在1995年，一个小型脱口秀节目关注了这个故事。你看到了一条金项链，大约……对。其实，我看到了……但我在五年前的纽瓦克机场弄丢了它。对。
Well, there's lots of jewelry inside, Oprah, and the way they price jewelry is, it's first. Well, we kind of joke, it felt like the Queen of England arrived. And truly, from that day forward, it changed everything. It was a game changer. Today, all kinds of people show up to shop at the Unclaimed Baggage Center. Tourists, locals, people who make one annual giant shopping pilgrimage, millionaire shop for discount Rolexes next to everyday people looking for a new cheap winter
好吧，里面有珠宝，奥普拉，他们给珠宝定价的方式是，首先。好吧，我们开玩笑说，感觉就像英国女王来了。真的，从那天起，一切都改变了。这是一个游戏规则的改变者。今天，各种各样的人来到无主行李中心购物。游客、当地人、每年进行一次巨型购物朝圣的人、与寻找廉价冬装的普通人并肩为打折劳力士而购物的百万富翁。
jacket, or just maybe, if they're lucky, Oprah's gold necklace. But a few of the items that come through Unclaimed Baggage are just too special to sell, like Hoggle from Labyrinth. He's still there. As soon as you walk through the front door, Hoggle is there on your left. And once workers opened up a bag and found a camera from the space shuttle, this was one of the earliest iterations of the digital camera, only three were ever made. So, Unclaimed Baggage, give that one back. Other things that turn up at Unclaimed Baggage
或者如果他们足够幸运，能找到奥普拉的金项链。但是，流转到无主行李中心的少数物品实在太特殊而无法出售，比如《魔幻迷宫》里的霍格（Hoggle）。他还在那儿。一走进前门，霍格就在你的左边。曾经有工作人员打开一个包，发现了一台来自航天飞机的相机，这是数码相机最早的版本之一，总共只制作了三台。所以，无主行李中心，把那个还回去吧。在无主行李中心出现的其他东西
are genuinely rare and contain these huge stories of humanity and culture. Thinking back over my time, I can remember a trunk of Versace runway gowns that came through, just fresh off the runway. Around the same time, can remember a trunk of Versace runway gowns that came through, just fresh off the runway. Around the same time, there was a truncful of amazing hand painted kimonos. A Tibetan ceremonial horn, a handmade Polynesian grass skirt, a medicine stick, likely from a tribe in the Amazon, with a ceremonial shrunken head still attached.
则真正罕见，并包含着这些宏大的人类和文化故事。回想我的经历，我记得有一箱范思哲（Versace）T台礼服经过这里，刚刚从T台上撤下。大约在同一时间，我记得有一箱范思哲T台礼服经过这里，刚刚从T台上撤下。大约在同一时间，有一箱令人惊叹的手绘和服。一把西藏法号、一条手工制作的波利尼西亚草裙、一根可能来自亚马逊部落的药棍，上面还附有一个仪式的干缩人头。
One day, this well-worn Gucci suitcase showed up at the store, and inside, it was filled with Egyptian artifacts, including a burial mask that dated to about 1,500 BC. Just around the time when the Phoenicians were putting the final touches on this thing called the alphabet. So, you know, old. Each non-descript roly bag that arrives at the Unclaimed Baguette Center brings a story with it. Not always as exciting as a lie-rattle snake or ancient Egyptian artifacts, but still there's a story
有一天，这个磨损严重的古驰（Gucci）手提箱出现在店里，里面装满了埃及文物，包括一个可追溯到公元前1500年左右的墓葬面具。大约在腓尼基人给这个叫做字母表的东西做最后润色的时候。所以，你知道的，它很古老。每一个到达无主行李中心的不起眼的滚轮包都带有一个故事。虽然并不总是像响尾蛇或古埃及文物那样令人兴奋，但依然有一个故事
there. Who was this person? Where were they going? Why do they still have a hair crimper? Where were they going? Why do they still have a hair crimper? Where were they gonna wear those glittery golden sneakers? Were they actually using this iPod Nano, or did it just slip into a crevice in their bag and get lost twice over? Does the toddler who lost their panda-blanky miss it? the The Unclaimed Baggage Center is open every day of the week, except Sundays. And if you can't make a trip to Scottsboro, Alabama, these days you can still do your bargain hunting
蕴含其中。这个人是谁？他们要去哪里？为什么他们还带着卷发器？他们要去哪里？为什么他们还带着卷发器？他们打算在哪里穿那些亮闪闪的金色运动鞋？他们真的在使用这个iPod Nano，还是它只是滑进了包里的缝隙里，不知不觉丢失了两次？那个弄丢了熊猫毯子的幼儿会想念它吗？无主行李中心每周除周日外每天营业。如果你无法前往阿拉巴马州斯科茨伯勒，如今你依然可以在
in their online store. But it really just gives you a taste of what you'll find in the real brick and mortar store. So if you're looking for a suit of armor or a hoggled doll, you better make your way down to Scottsboro. The Atlas Obscura podcast is hosted by Dylan Thurris and is a co-production of Atlas Obscura and Witness Dogs. The production team includes Chris Naka, Doug Boltinger, Camille Stanley, Sarah Wine, Manolo Morales, John DeLore, Willis Ryder Arnold,
他们的在线商店里购买便宜货。但这其实只是让你体验一下你在真正的实体店里会发现的东西。所以如果你在寻找一套盔甲或者一个霍格娃娃，你最好还是去一趟斯科茨伯勒。Atlas Obscura播客由迪伦·图里斯（Dylan Thurris）主持，是Atlas Obscura和Witness Dogs的联合制作。制作团队包括克里斯·纳卡（Chris Naka）、道格·博尔廷格（Doug Boltinger）、卡米尔·斯坦利（Camille Stanley）、萨拉·温（Sarah Wine）、马诺洛·莫拉莱斯（Manolo Morales）、约翰·德洛尔（John DeLore）、威利斯·赖德·阿诺德（Willis Ryder Arnold）、
Gianna Palmer, Tracy Samuelson, Baudelaire Sous, Peter Clowny, and Casey Hulfer, themed by Sam Tindal Mixed by Luz Flunny. The unclanded baggage episode was produced by Johanna Mayer. 99% invisible is Martin Gonzalez, who mixed this episode for us. Swan Riaw, Delaydi Hall, Kurt Colstead, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leye, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lawson Madonna, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family
吉安娜·帕尔默（Gianna Palmer）、特雷西·萨缪尔森（Tracy Samuelson）、博德莱尔·苏斯（Baudelaire Sous）、彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowny）和凯西·赫尔弗（Casey Hulfer），主题曲由山姆·廷德尔（Sam Tindal）创作，混音由卢兹·弗鲁尼（Luz Flunny）完成。无主行李这期节目由约翰娜·迈尔（Johanna Mayer）制作。99% Invisible由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）为我们混音。斯旺·里劳（Swan Riaw）、代莱迪·霍尔（Delaydi Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）、埃mett菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·莱耶（Vivian Leye）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、罗森·麦当娜（Lawson Madonna）、杰森·迪利昂（Jason Dillion）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，
now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org where on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org.
现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区上城潘多拉大楼以北六个街区处。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，在节目官方账号@99PI org互动，我们在Instagram和Reddit上也都有账号。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目以及99PI的每一期往期节目。
Thank you. Sail away with me, to the Loch Nogos, we can rely on each other. A-ah, fun one rom and to another. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。和我一起去罗克诺戈斯吧，我们可以相互依赖。啊哈，另一个有趣的罗马人。该剧集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。